foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear talking about a stone cold Classic
on this episode so this is the 1967
movie wait until dark and this was
another movie that um I had actually
sought out as a kid in the 1980s because
um kind of the third Act of it which is
you know very very famously like a
really tense sequence uh got mentioned
very favorably in the Stephen King book
dance Macabre which I've brought up many
many other times on this channel uh so
yeah so I had wanted to see it back then
and I remembered like really really
loving it I probably saw it when I was
13 14 years old something like that so I
was actually really excited to revisit
it for this series uh since I hadn't
seen it since then that I can remember
and I have to say that I'm very happy to
report that this movie absolutely holds
up in my opinion I think it's one of the
best it's like easily one of the most
effective Thrillers like of all time now
interestingly like the 2006 movie bug
that I just discussed a few days ago
which was directed by William friedkin
Wait Until Dark was also an adaptation
of a successful stage play that takes
place almost entirely in one location
like one room one apartment uh no I did
not intentionally review two based on a
play movies in the same week on purpose
unless my subconscious is smarter than I
am which you know that's that's a
possibility I suppose but I just I
didn't mean to do it like at least
consciously now the Stage production uh
this time around of Wait Until Dark was
written by Frederick Knott who didn't
write a lot of plays like over his
career but he also uh wrote I mean you
really don't have to write that many if
you wrote like one or two really really
good ones which this guy did the other
one that he's known for other than this
one is the 1952 play dial M for Murder
which of course was made into the
classic Alfred Hitchcock film from 1954.
now the film adaptation of Wait Until
Dark was directed by none other than
parents Young Who at this point was best
known for directing three count of three
James Bond films uh Dr No from 1962 From
Russia with Love from 1963 and
Thunderball from
1965. now in the stage version of wait
until dark at least like the the widely
seen like a Broadway version Lee Remick
actually starred in the main role she
was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff but I think
most horror nerds like me recognize her
as Damien's mom from The Omen from 1976
uh but yeah she was in the stage version
however uh the producer of the movie uh
is it it's Mel Ferrer it's Ferrer right
I mean I've heard it pronounced like
lots of different ways I know the guy's
name like he's famous but it's like I
keep hearing it but I'm just gonna say
that
um but he had actually he was the
producer on this and he had actually
specifically obtained the rights to
Frederick Knott's play as a vehicle for
Audrey Hepburn who was than his wife he
wanted her to be able to kind of show
off like how wide her range was like her
acting chops now uh the hell of that was
though
that Mel and Audrey Hepburn were in the
midst of divorcing when this movie was
being shot
um so obviously that was there was a lot
of personal stress that uh that Audrey
Hepburn was going through and this role
was kind of like demanding uh both
emotionally and a bit physically as well
so she was like not having a good time
and she actually ended up losing 15
pounds like from the stress and stuff
like that and if you've seen Audrey
Hepburn she can't really afford to lose
15 pounds anywhere she is a tiny tiny
woman uh so yeah so she looks very very
fragile in this movie but in a way I
think that kind of I know that's
terrible and you don't want that to
happen to anybody but it really did kind
of like inform her character and make
her seem like I said more fragile more
vulnerable and so that kind of made you
like sympathize with her all the more
um and I have to say that her
performance in this is incredible she
really Rose to the challenge this
actually earned her her fifth Oscar
Nomine domination although I will say
too that um I think that was the last
Oscar nomination that she bought after
that she got after this movie though I
think she kind of like semi-retired I
don't think she was in another movie for
like another decade after this like
maybe until like the mid to late 70s if
I'm remembering correctly so yeah it
kind of did a little bit of a number on
her but like I said she got a Academy
Award nomination and deservedly so
because uh she's [ __ ] great in this
so at the very beginning of the movie we
meet this woman named Lisa uh who's
played by Samantha Jones and she's
picking up this antique doll which this
older guy is like sewing all these
little packets of heroin into it like
into the stuffing now incidentally
although Lisa is referred to in the
stage play she never appears as an
actual character so this whole opening
sequence like with her picking up the
drugs and going to the airport and
everything like that is a film only
Edition like in the play obviously
because the play you know is by
necessity kind of set in one location
they didn't really have the wherewithal
to do like all of these bigger things
like that so so all this opening thing
was like the airport and her getting the
doll and everything like that does not
happen in the play so after a few
moments we surmise that Lisa is
obviously a drug mule and she's
smuggling all this heroin which is a lot
I'm not big I don't I'm not up on heroin
so I don't really know like how
expensive that it must be really
expensive because everybody's trying to
get it but uh you know so I don't so I
don't know but she's smuggling this
heroine uh into New York City from
Montreal
upon arriving at the airport though she
starts to become really really nervous
when she sees this kind of intimidating
looking beat-nicky looking dude who's
like watching her and she decides that
she's gonna ditch the drugs
so she ends up pawning the doll off on
the stranger that she met on the plane
now this stranger is a photographer
Named Sam Hendricks who's played by
Ephraim Zimbalist Jr
and she basically gives him some kind of
like [ __ ] and Bull story about oh this
doll's a present for my niece but then I
forgot to get my other knee something
and they're gonna get jealous so can you
just hang on to this for a little bit
and then like give me your address and
I'll come over later and pick it up and
all this other kind of stuff and he's
just like whatever okay whatever and he
just like sticks in his luggage and
doesn't really think about it anymore so
after that whole exchange like Lisa gets
kind of roughly whisked Away by the beat
Nikki intimidating looking man uh who
didn't actually see that whole doll
exchange or so were led to believe now
sometime later this beat Nikki
intimidating man uh who actually turns
out to be criminal mastermind Harry
wrote who's played by Alan Arkin who is
fantastic in this
he summons two of his little criminal
Associates to this kind of small like
seller level apartment in Greenwich
Village in New York City these two
Associates are Mike who's played by
Richard Crenna and carlino who's played
by Jack Weston
now rote tells these two guys he
summoned them I'm assuming because
they're really good like con men you
know I mean they run like long cons on
people
so he basically tells them hey this is
Lisa's Place and this doll that has all
this heroin in it is somewhere in this
apartment and I need you guys's help to
find out where she sashed it soon enough
though like while Mark Mike and carlino
are doing the search they realize that
this is actually not Lisa's Place at all
and what's even worse than that is that
they find Lisa dead in a locked closet
so it's only then that they figure out
that rote has killed Lisa and then has
kind of like fooled them or essentially
like a blackmailed them into helping him
out because he's like hey um you know
Lisa's dead in this apartment and you
[ __ ] touched every single thing
in here
um you know and he's like hey I've got
gloves on I was thinking ahead like they
were just helping him look for the doll
they thought it was Lisa's Place they
found it it wasn't but it was too late
then and he's like you're never gonna be
able to like wipe down this whole entire
place or remember everything that you
touched yeah so he's like so obviously
if I leave Lisa's body in here uh and I
call the cops then they're going to want
to find you guys because your uh
fingerprints are already on file and
blah blah so they've basically been
forced not only into helping wrote like
dump the body
but they also kind of get roped into
this scheme that rote has cooked up in
order to find out where the doll is now
he says I've searched this entire
apartment and I can't find the doll so
he reasons that the doll has to be in
this little safe um that's in the living
room and if he can't get it open so he's
pretty much devised this really
complicated charade in order to get into
the safe and he needs these two guys
particular set of skills like to help
him out with this plan so obviously it
turns out that this apartment actually
belongs to the photographer Sam
Hendricks the guy that Lisa met on the
plane and gave the doll to now obviously
he is just like a completely uninvolved
party he just ended up with this doll
because like I said she met him on the
plane it was like here take this and
he's just like okay whatever so he
doesn't know it's anything that's going
on now Sam uh furthermore is married to
a woman named Susie played by the
aforementioned Audrey Hepburn now
Susie's character she was in a car
accident the year before and
um she went by blind like she lost her
sight in the accident so she's still so
her disability is very recent and she's
still kind of trying to adapt to it now
she is very determined
um but she still kind of has some
difficulties like navigating the world
because like I said she's not really
used to it yet now she does have some
help with some tasks like grocery
shopping and stuff like that from this
bratty preteen that lives upstairs named
Gloria but her relatively new husband is
encouraging her sometimes in a dickish
way I think like to be as self-reliant
as possible she's also going to Blind
school to kind of teach her how to
adjust now the interesting thing like I
said is that I kind of feel like there's
a little bit of thing going on here with
Sam because Sam he met her after the
accident because there's a thing where
she tells the story about like she's
still she was still adapting to her
blindness she hadn't been blind very
long and she almost apparently like
walked into the road and got hit by a
bus or something like that and like Sam
saved her and so then subsequently they
had like kind of World Romance and then
they got married so I don't really know
if there's some kind and Sam like I said
really sort of
I don't know if he's necessarily pushing
her but I'm I mean you could say that
he's like he has faith that she'll you
know that she's determined enough like
to get her [ __ ] together so he doesn't
want to coddle her it does come across a
little bit as him being just like an
[ __ ] sometimes but you know it's like
she'll drop something and he'll she'll
be like hey can I have a hint like where
it's at and he's like you'll find it
like kind of making her crawl around on
the floor like to find it and stuff so I
don't know like I said I can kind of see
where he's coming from but he kind of
comes across a little a little Gruff
about it but you know there's that whole
thing too and I don't know I think that
she has a little bit in the beginning of
the movie has a little bit of I don't
want I don't know if I'd go so far so I
call it codependence but she is kind of
like dependent on him particularly
because he saved her life and so I think
there's a little bit of that going on
too like I said it's not overt but that
was kind of like the vibe that I got so
pretty much like the main after all of
this is established and set up like the
main meat of the story is involving
these three criminals Mike and carlino
and wrote and they're really really
horrible like treacherous plan to take
advantage of Susie's blindness in order
to get her to open the safe where they
think the doll is
so they go I mean it's a pretty
elaborate scheme uh they concoct this
kind of phony far away photo shoot like
in Asbury Park or something like that
which that's New Jersey right in that
New Jersey I know that from Bruce
Springsteen but you know what I mean I
don't know I've only been in New Jersey
once in my whole entire life so uh so
yeah so they concoct this kind of like
phony thing like oh they they set up a
model and everything who doesn't show up
and then he has to wait and it's like
really far away from the apartment so
he's gonna be out of the apartment so
she's gonna be the only one there and so
after that's all taken care of then they
put this like elaborate ruse into action
like Mike Richard crenna's character he
takes on the good guy role which is that
was kind of one thing and like I said I
don't even think this is a weakness but
Richard Crenna I mean he was enough he
was in everything like in the 60s and
70s I feel like he was in all the movies
but I kind of feel like he always played
a good guy so it was like really
interesting to see him play a villain in
this but he is the most sympathetic of
the villains because it seems like wrote
Alan arkin's character I mean he's just
straight up evil bowl and just a
cold-blooded [ __ ] whereas the
other two are also criminals but they at
least still have like some Humanity to
them so it kind of I guess because I'm
so used to seeing Richard Crenna like in
good guy roles it was really hard to see
him as a villain so and I don't know
like the movie almost kind of plays into
that a little bit because the role that
he's playing is like hey I'm the good
guy and then like when the other two
guys that are like in on the [ __ ] are
trying to like um you know threaten her
and things like that he's like hey you
knock that off you know what I mean so
they have like this whole kind of thing
going on so he kind of comes in first
and pretends to be like an old buddy of
sans like her husband's like from the
Marines and he basically starts acting
like as the plan unfolds he starts
acting as like the confidante and the
protector like you know I'm friends with
your husband and he pretends to know all
this stuff because like you know she
hasn't been married to Sam very long so
she doesn't know that much about him he
even like takes advantage of her being
blind and you know because Sam's a
photographer and he's like oh look
there's a picture of me on the wall
because he knows she can't see it you
know what I mean so there's that you
know it's kind of shitty but there's
that whole thing uh carlino the other
guy he pretends to be a cop his whole
thing is he's investigating the
mysterious death of this woman who is
found dumped like in an alley or
something like that not too far away
from the apartment now obviously we know
that this is Lisa who wrote has killed
but they just dumped her there making it
look like oh it says you know somebody
else and what they're trying to do like
carlino's cop character he's trying to
persuade Susie that uh her husband Sam
was having an affair with Lisa and maybe
like bumped her off he's like I don't
know if I believe that but the cops
might believe that so I need you to help
me out like you know clear your
husband's name so they're coming at it
from that angle too
now wrote Alan arkin's character he
plays like multiple roles like the main
one probably pretending to be Lisa's
jealous husband which sort of like
bolsters the narrative that they're
trying to push off on her that her
husband Sam was having an affair with
this woman and possibly maybe killed her
so because Susie can't see them or see
what's going on around her like if they
for example like if they tell her hey
there's a cop car parked outside she
just kind of has to take their word for
it so yeah so she kind of has to take
everything at face value because she
can't really see what's going on but as
the story goes on her resourcefulness
like the fact that her hearing is
getting better like things like that and
she's like super super smart too also it
kind of like as it goes along helps her
realize that the danger that she's
actually in from these guys and
ultimately kind of helps her
fight back against these attackers who
have underestimated her like thinking
that she's just this little vulnerable
blind woman so I mean wait until dark
really benefits immensely from it has a
very very tight narrative it's like
really well plotted it has like a really
claustrophobic atmosphere like I said
almost all of it takes place in this one
very small Greenwich Village apartment
with only a few scenes outside of that
all the acting is terrific really really
good the score by Henry Mancini is
actually really good as well and I think
one of the things that helps too is that
Audrey Hepburn
as an actress she's just comes across
like so sweet and so vulnerable and then
the fact that she's blind as well so you
kind of feel like this instant Affinity
with her and you kind of it's weird
because you kind of get mad when as
you're watching like these three hoods
like taking advantage of her disability
like for their own evil ends just to get
this doll that's filled with heroine is
like really really maddening because
it's almost like and I've seen some
reviewers be like man leave Audrey
Hepburn alone you know what I mean so I
think the fact that she's just so she's
just this tiny bird-like like sweet
little woman and then the fact that they
made her blind and that these like these
three guys are like in her apartment and
like she can't see them and she like
senses somebody's in there but like she
can't like tell and it's like it's like
really really like nail biting like to
watch so and you really also can't help
but root for her when she kind of Twigs
onto what's going on and then uses her
considerable intelligence to start
giving them some pushback now even
though this isn't a straight up horror
movie per se uh the final 20 minutes or
so is really kind of like a master class
in scary suspense building and is easily
one of the most terrifying sequences
ever put on film and like I said you
watch any uh you know top 100 like
scariest horror scenes or something like
that I can almost guarantee that this is
going to be on there and for very good
reason
um so at the end like it's come down to
the final battle between Susie and rote
and Susie I mean knows that she's
outmatched so she pretty brilliantly
levels the playing field and it's like I
have to say because I was like I
probably wouldn't have thought of doing
this but you know good for her but she
levels the playing field by knocking out
every single light in the apartment like
breaking all the lights so that rote
will be just as blind as she is so she
has a chance she has to give him like
the same handicap that she has now in
the theatrical run of Wait Until Dark
back in 1967 so the story goes
um the theater owners were actually
instructed to turn off all the lights in
the auditorium I guess within legal
boundaries or whatever during this
sequence because the sequence of the
movie is completely black there is no
light no nothing and all you can hear is
like breathing and dialogue and [ __ ]
like that so when you're in the theater
and if you were just plunged into this
ultimate darkness and then like the
screen is also dark and all you can hear
is like their dialogue and their
breathing and it's like really really
tense so it's kind of putting you in the
same situation as Susie like there's
somebody in this tiny apartment that
wants to kill you and you can't [ __ ]
see them and you don't know if they can
see you because you're blind and you
can't see so it's like it's terrifying
terrifying and it's like just really
genius I hesitate to call it a gimmick
because that sounds reductive I mean I
guess it kind of is but it's just really
really well done if it's a gimmick it's
it's a [ __ ] great one
um and even nowadays it works
brilliantly I think it's like really
really cool
um I have to say though although Susie
does forget get one single light but in
all fairness most of us probably would
have forgotten it as well so I'm not
gonna like give her too much uh hassle
about that uh but she is actually able
to kind of win the day just through her
determination and her Ingenuity and
stuff like that so if you're into
Thrillers at all and have somehow not
seen Wait Until Dark please do yourself
a favor and get on it it's one of the
best examples of the Thriller genre and
has I mean in my opinion has not dated
at all
um it just has this great sense of
unease and just potential Menace uh
through the whole entire run time Audrey
Hepburn is like so great she's just so
sympathetic and she just gets you
invested immediately and like pulling
for the whole time you're like oh no oh
my God like the poor you know what I
mean as all of this [ __ ] is like
happening around her
um Alan Arkin have to say is also
amazing as uh roach who's just like just
this cooly malevolent [ __ ]
um and just he's just the [ __ ] worst
but he's so great you you can tell that
he's like really having fun like with
this role like he's just really like
making a meal of it and it's great uh
and honestly like the last part of this
with like the two actors just like
matching wits in this tiny like dark
apartment is just I mean you're just
like white knuckling it the whole time
it's just really really good I mean this
one is a classic for a reason and uh
it's just an easy recommend if you like
Thrillers or if you like any movies from
this time period or anything I mean this
is definitely one that everybody should
see because it's great so that'll do it
for this flickers of fear I will see you
guys again on the next one bye